welcome to this video playing cool
effects from Austria let's see c4 okay I
don't have a particularly great score
against them let's see what I can do
with this b6 line yeah d for now is
normally played and it doesn't you just
don't want to get rid of his weak d4d
four square interesting so I'm i work in
that I just keep default under control
him should guarantee me quite a quite a
nice position and easy to play motel i
can try to do something on the queenside
yeah I was just thinking about it this d
6 square but I think I can just just
cover this right queen is not brilliant
on c7 but also not bad I my turn okay
okay don't don't mind that really
getting the Knight to f5 is part of
blacks game plan anyway with the knight
on e4 ever look the aid and d5 also gets
a bit more attractive uh-huh Willie
before should I play d5 now maybe
immediately
that's probably not bad just try to get
to this position where I have four
against three on the queenside and I
don't really see any great compensation
for Hawaii yeah f5 maybe you wants to
play a five sunlight f5 a bishop t5 this
herb this type of my DM hmm interesting
maybe I shouldn't cover this on before i
also have c4 now before c4 looks good
and you know other moves then before I
didn't really make much sense but this
makes quite a good volley takes really
well this snow looks very nice now
doesn't it isn't it it is looking what
this is what is this idea yeah Queen a4
maybe I thought 94 would be just good
possibly with be five and the sepan
running I can also just push the sea
pawn hmm apt okay let's let's put this
only 44 it's probably good anyway so not
waste them big time on that I really
don't see a great reply I have b5
possibly coming and yeah hear hear it it
is such a case b5 as possible why can
just play Knight f5 which is also good
young threatening to take on only three
killing his structure really yeah this
is okay
and now we have it's both good yeah
Bishop takes is also not bad threatening
night takes g3 but I think this is
probably better night e 2 C 3 was check
as the threat one threat I don't really
see what is movers he also has so it's
very badly placed night on g 592 c3 and
b5 those two ideas are hard to meet ya
ok and so is getting out of the checks
should i play b5 now or hmm i guess so
Queen a six Luke g6 screen be seven or
something like this but I have very good
play with this with a/c pawn ok it's
just retreating interesting how do I
continue here I mean the Queen cannot
move easily a 5 c 3 also c 3 is not not
bad c3 Roxy one probably si tu cuenta
three it's not a direct win okay so
let's improve position a bit more
oh really I play here right rooks take
what what are you doing now si tu as the
threat and rook see what I take before
I okay just just keep it simple take him
and play be three if those two points do
not win here I really and there's not
much I can do about it where do I go I
guess here right not running into 94like
2594 90s no square relief for the Queen
okay rook be one pc to should be
convincing enough okay well this move I
can I can take it or queen bee three
queen bee three is better right I think
I should win the whole work not just not
just an exchange okay okay okay I didn't
see that one I can take here though ok
just take look here
two then play C to add this promotes
this promotes the whole bunch see to my
cheeks the average this is basically
just a check or hearing yeah I didn't
see that check coming so he can infect
and promote here okay I could have taken
the bishop it wasn't a double check okay
but he really has no threat here right I
can take everyone yeah there was
certainly there's I some easier ways but
i think it was it was good enough yeah i
really had a good position out of the
opening all this didn't help i guess
this 94 enter and so on yeah i mean here
i think you should probably play some
some moves like you know Bishop d2
rookie won those kind of do nothing
moves this is just helping me i mean i'm
pretty sure that the sea porn is just
dangerous yeah supported by 94 and maybe
you should not take it i mean after the
capture I think this should be winning
what does the comp giving minus two yeah
okay yeah I think it's really just too
much the porn there are those threats
everything is in play and why does not
coordinated at all here I could have
played this already yeah before and I
thought that night f5 is just good I
mean it is good but ready to see three I
should just take the exchange
but ok this is so fantastic position b5
quindi one and it's always minus 2 like
black seems to win and in almost all
cases yeah this is desperation move but
i get i get this pawn ruling this is Sir
just just too much 94 look sir looks a
bit tougher let's say something like
this takes takes maybe here also I have
this idea yeah it was just a very good
position for black okay thanks for
watching